so as many of you know because you've
emailed me about it I was on Fox News
yesterday and I had a discussion with
Kyle kolinsky of secular talk before and
I was basically talking to him about
whether we think that it's worth doing
Fox News knowing that it gets so stacked
against the left discussed knowing that
it's mostly an echo chamber of
unthinking reflexive conservative I hate
to even call it thought they're sort of
non thought because you might get
somebody who's willing to hear another
point of view or do you just say no and
Kyle's view was any opportunity to show
up and actually get your voice heard in
front of people who disagree is an
opportunity to change someone's mind and
therefore it's worth it so I decided to
do it I was invited
Leland Vitter was the host bitter I
think is his last name
I was opposite Philadelphia radio host
Don Giordano of course in an attempt to
I guess not give me the credit that
could have been given to me they called
me Boston radio host opposite Dom as
Philadelphia radio host of course
implying that I guess host local radio
in Boston and don't have a syndicated
show I think it's a swipe at new media
maybe should you they don't want to
recognize that platform they also didn't
make any mention of the online platform
that's also true the topic was the
trumped Putin summit mostly they also
said right before going on that it was
going to be a four-minute segment unless
it went really well
the idea of having two guests on for a
four-minute segment is clearly what you
do when you don't actually want to
explore ideas and depth which they don't
and they also said to me before going on
engage with each other which we know
what that means it means start arguing
with each other so my strategy going in
and I'm gonna play the clip for you is I
knew that as soon as I would try to
explain a point given that there were
four minutes allocated for an interview
with two guests they would try to
interrupt me so my goal was stick to
what I want to say if interrupted go
back to what I want to say and see what
I can do and you will immediately
realize that whenever I actually started
to make a point I would immediately be
interrupted and given some kind of
different question to answer and it was
a completely expected tactic there was
also the attempt made by the
most to take on my views sort of in
addition to this dom guy so it ended up
being not surprisingly me against the
conservative guest and the host leland
Vitter but I I expected this stuff right
I went in knowing that last thing people
pointed out that I look extraordinarily
white compared to the other two I don't
know if this is done deliberately but
I've noticed that many times the leftist
guest is poorly lit and the second I
walked into the studio where I I just
sit in a dark room to do this and join
them via satellite I immediately saw
compared to our lighting here which
makes me look sort of like a human being
it's too white I'm there I don't know if
it's deliberate or not but this is not
going to look right and not surprisingly
I didn't look orange which is a good
thing but I definitely looked like a
vampire so let's get into the first part
of this interview on Fox News and let's
talk about this with Dom Giordano David
Pakman radio host in their respective
cities Philadelphia and Boston as they
are gentlemen nice to see you Dom what's
striking is when you listen to the
president's advisers whether it be John
Huntsman national security riser Bolden
or others they are far harsher in their
rhetoric than the president what do you
make of it that's true Leland and I wish
the President were a harsher in his but
the actions of President Trump what his
administration is actually doing we put
more sanctions on Putin we've kicked out
more of the delegates from the Soviet
before from Russia so his actions have
been firm in this manner and I think
it's way overblown that he's going to
give away the store a president Trump is
not going to do that in any kind of
negotiation
I wish the rhetoric though we're more
direct toward Putin that's where I
usually am David it brings up an
interesting point it is the less problem
with President Trump among many that
they have the way he goes about foreign
policy or actually the substance of it
because his David points out our Dom
points out he's been pretty tough on
Putin much tougher than Obama in many
ways by selling youthful weapons to the
Ukrainians yeah I think that the problem
really is the easily manipulable reality
of Donald Trump and I think if we want a
sort of a preview of what we could
expect with Putin we look at what
happened with Kim
John moon where Donald Trump claimed
victory on the basis of the exact same
vague promises that we've gotten from
North Korea before tweeted on the way
back that the nuclear threat is over and
we just learned that in that vein the
president just tweeted even this morning
he said wait a second he said it's been
nine months there hasn't been a nuclear
test and there hasn't been a missile
test so there's the first interruption
and now all of a sudden it's not David
and Dom it's dom and leland against
david and i tried to just stick with it
so when they came back to me i just
continued the same point i was trying to
make and of course there were continuing
efforts made to derail why shouldn't he
get credit for that the as i was saying
just days after the supposed victory in
opening the door of new relations kim
jongwan went to a potato farm instead of
meeting with trump's secretary of state
showing that there was really nothing
there so my what i'm anticipating from
this summit with putin would be that
Donald Trump will be incredibly
impressed with Putin's sense of humor
much like he was with Kim Jong Un's he's
a great guy so on and so forth I would
be worried especially after the NATO
summit just days ago where Trump started
hinting at maybe we go this thing our
own way that plays right into what Putin
wants so I wouldn't be surprised if that
gets pushed along a little bit of a way
as well a fair critique and something to
be worried about no even I don't think
that's the case again again with Kim
jong-un he is not testing missiles again
he's not getting to that final step
where he's able to hit it that's what's
important not all the posturing do I
wish President Trump were more buttoned
up and sounded as say a John Bolton
might yes I do when it comes to Putin so
now they both latch on to this talking
point hey Kim jong-un hasn't tested a
missile in nine months Dom does it and
the host does it and eventually I just
asked them to tell me why is that
something that Trump gets credit for and
I admit I actually kind of bungled it I
I think I did not handle this part as
well I was not as articulate as I wanted
to be that's his style
you guys David I think we all like his
style you don't like his style but the
results are there there are certainly no
results to speak of yet well hold on
David is that really is that really fair
you got nine months without a nuclear
weapons test you got nine months with
a missile test there's there's a new
report that there's actually an
advancement in the nuclear research
capabilities in norther clear because I
think that there's going to be
allegations here that I am unwilling to
see progress I actually was hoping for a
real victory I've been following the
North Korea crisis for more than 10
years on my program so I was I am
committed actually I believe it's one of
the main humanitarian crises that we do
let me get a question in in reality
though president Trump was able to get a
nine-month moratorium on nuclear weapons
testing and on missile testing this from
a regime that President Obama said was
the single greatest threat to the United
States when he met with President Trump
how is that not an accomplishment in and
of itself regardless of the other issues
if all of a sudden the focus is who in
the past said that someone is AG just
answer that you've got to go back to the
drawing board that's exactly what the
entire Republican Party said about the
question just answer the question how is
no missile testing and no nuclear
weapons testing in nine months not an
accomplishment explain what Trump did to
call it an accomplishment okay knock
yourself out I yeah I die they pretend
not to know what I'm asking and I think
it was pretty clear what I was asking
but yet I should have asked that I think
in a better way like for example France
also hasn't bombed Italy for the last
nine months does Trump get credit for
that or something something along those
lines I think it was okay but still they
of course had no answer to that
I mean hindsight's 2020 yes but I think
you still illustrated the point and I
think they were both stumped there they
just wanted to make it seem as if you
were the one who was asking a crazy
question they just can't understand what
crazy things I'm saying okay and then it
just goes sort of downhill from there
here's the rest of the interview it
comes back to again it is an
accomplishment and I'll be bipartisan it
was President Bush President Clinton all
American presidents couldn't break
through and even meet with this guy and
talk with him he was approaching the
final steps to be able to hit us he is
not a there's no American
that's that's the truth he is not he is
standing damn you did that no I'd rather
city a harsher light this is an echo
chamber talking point that Trump was
able to achieve something by securing a
meeting North Korean leaders have been
desperate to get the recognition David
would have during a main residence and
it was the president was his tactics
it was the Trump tactics that got the
meeting and who knows maybe woke up Kim
jong-un to know every ality of this
versus other American presidents all
right we move on real no evidence of
that move on real quickly to the
president's interview with CBS this
morning that aired about the hacking of
emails by the Russian government take a
listen what the president said I think
the DNC should be ashamed of themselves
for allowing themselves be hacked they
had bad defenses and they were able to
be hacked but I heard they were trying
to pack the Republicans too but and this
may be wrong but they had much stronger
defenses David is it a fair critique
that for as much as the Democrats cry
and scream about Russian collusion and
or Russian intervention in the election
it was Democrats who were in charge of
the national security apparatus when it
happened the the idea here that if you
are a victim of hacking it's the fault
of the victim when you don't want to
blame that heat that party who did the
hacking is absolutely hilarious and
anybody who doesn't see the absurdity of
that on its face it's going to be very
hard to actually engage on the facts
when it comes to that and what what the
the real big news related to this is
that we now know that when Donald Trump
quote jokingly said hey if Russia wants
to hack Hillary's emails that wouldn't
be a bad thing the first attempt to do
that happen within hours of that
statement that's really the news DOM and
Leo and I would counter that we do know
from the Rosenstein report on Friday the
big news is no American citizen
committed any act of collusion or crime
and there's no evidence the Russians
were effective I don't like what the
Russians did either but they weren't
effective
and you got to knock off this witch-hunt
wait it's wait a second guys hold on
hold on a second wait wait a second a
witch-hunt that finds 32 witches already
is not exactly a witch number 2 when you
say no American citizens have been
accused of crimes Paul Manafort I think
his American I know a lot of Americans
did the crime of colluding with the
Russians he's not accused of that
collusion is not what's any witches
thank you very much we appreciate it
obviously a spirited discussion went on
a little bit longer than we thought it
would which is a good thing we'll see
you guys soon yeah so I was immediately
flooded with insane hate mail on
Facebook Twitter Email even Instagram a
few samples John wrote in saying I just
decided to take a Google search on you
and wow what a waste the usual arrogant
condescending idiot probably successful
in your target market have a nice life
Frank Roden how does this tool even have
a radio show is your studio located on
Newbury Street thank God for Howie Carr
Ron I don't know what that bottom-line I
think that's an ex that that is my type
over there Ron wrote in if you intended
to embarrass yourself on Fox News you
did Joe after eight years of vacillation
and cowardice by Obama and Clinton
incorporated your nonsensical hysteria
over your mythical Trump ski is
laughable you are just another mindless
pole smoker hiding out in the wannabe
totalitarian one-party city-state of
Boston you are yet another useless faux
liberal air thief who has never had a
real job we have a couple others Pat
wrote in not this Pat no one likes a
smug evasive liberal dumbass and lastly
Mike saw you on Fox News today how in
the hell do you keep a show you are a
brain-dead [ __ ] you have been following
North Korea really what does that mean
thank God for you there is lowlife trash
Democrats that follow your show you are
a joke what a clown stay in Boston great
place for you millions of us are
grateful for all the amazing work our
president has done sorry piece of
garbage Hillary did not win but thank
God for our country we have a real man
for president not a pathetic joke like
you so my question is is it worth doing
this is it worth doing this or is it
just a total waste of time that's my
question to you and I look forward to
hearing from you about it a killing
Obamacare killing Obamacare has been an
obsession
of number one Republicans when Obama was
still president remember the dozens and
dozens what was it 60 70 80 attempts 261
61 votes to repeal Obamacare in the
house and number two getting rid of
Obamacare has been a priority of Donald
Trump's since he's become President of
the United States and what has been able
to what he has been able to do to attack
Obamacare are basically two things
number one Trump's tax reform plan
remove that individual mandate from the
tax plan and that piece of it I think
you said Pat doesn't get enacted until
next year is it the actual removal of
the mandate it's not entirely sure about
that one yeah at some point that that
gets enabled and that will make it so
that you no longer pay a penalty if you
don't have individual health insurance
that is meant to financially destabilize
the system it's meant to hurt Obamacare
as a to create a pretext to then get rid
of it number two
Donald Trump's administration abruptly
suspended payments to Obamacare programs
and as I've talked to you about before
if you can't get rid of the law get rid
of the money that makes the law work and
the administration is doing indeed that
ten point four billion dollars in
payments to insurers were suspended
abruptly by the Trump administration the
insurers of course immediately said well
if we don't get this money through the
ACA arrangement we're just going to
increase premiums on customers to make
up the difference and withholding these
funds is such a disaster that the
Republican chairman of the House Ways
and Means Committee Republican
congressman Kevin Brady not exactly a
moderate Republican a pretty far-right
ideologue he is now asking the Trump
administration to restart those payments
and as a reminder this guy's hugely
against Obamacare the hugely against
Obamacare and he recognizes the disaster
that this is and the House Ways and
Means Committee recognizes how much of a
disaster this is the Republicans are so
concerned about the elimination of these
payments that they are considering
legislative action to force the payments
to restart Republican president stops
the payments Republican committee leader
might pass legislation to start them
back up think about how insane this is
and by the way don't think for a second
that Republicans are doing this because
of some moral responsibility that they
feel the midterms are coming that's all
it is Democrats are already starting to
talk about the rising premiums that have
been taking place and are going to
continue with these funds suspended and
Republicans know that they will suffer
if premiums continue to explode because
of this decision by Donald Trump for all
we know as soon as the midterms are over
the Republicans will go back to trump
and say have at it you can resuspend
those payments we don't have an election
coming up
but for the bottom-dwelling Trumpets who
are supposedly fiscal conservatives they
are already saying Pat this is taxpayer
money this is good this is ten point
four billion in taxpayer money that's
not being used for Obamacare and to them
I would say you were wrong this is money
collected from insurers whose pool of
customers is on average healthier and
redistributed to the insurers who are
doing a good thing mind you insuring
less healthy people it's a
redistribution meant to not penalize
insurance companies for insuring less
healthy people it's insurance company
money it's not taxpayer money yeah so
unless the American people are just by
and large looking out for the good of
big insurance companies rapists it
really shouldn't bother them that much
there is such a heart heartwarming
sentiment for the corporate health
insurance industrial complex in this
country that it makes perfect sense that
people would have a special place in
their heart for these wait a sec what
what the hell am I talking about
most important overarching story here is
that for seven years the Republicans
slammed Obamacare they took 60 something
votes in the house to repeal it knowing
it would never happen they campaigned
and so did Trump on as soon as Trump is
in office it's out Obamacare is out and
the public is opposed to the repeal of
Obamacare every iteration proposed by
Republicans to repeal Obamacare would
have led to tens of millions or multiple
tens of millions I guess is what it
would I mean of people ending up without
health insurance and what they're doing
instead is they're taking these small
cuts that Obamacare to
further try to sabotage it or sabotage
if you are of William Shatner's
pronunciation sabotage Obamacare from
succeeding great leadership and vision
right seven years to come up with
something everything they propose is
garbage they can't get it done and now
Republicans are going to Trump and
saying please restart these payments
yeah and Republicans now own the issue
of health care right because do they
can't just gut the Affordable Care Act
and do nothing to replace it and I don't
know what they're gonna do going forward
but if this is their only strategy it's
not gonna be very good for them that's
an empirical analysis based on actual
facts and data I am not convinced that
short of exploding premiums even above
like the underlying increase in premiums
that Republican hardline voters are
actually going to say that it's
Republicans who were to blame for this
because you know what they'll say it's
Obama care if Obama hadn't put this in
place in the first place the fact that
it's not working right wouldn't matter
forget the fact that it's Republicans
who are making sure that it doesn't work
correctly really bad really bad and we
will see what impact it has on the
election but more importantly people's
lives are at stake
Republicans are playing politics with
this because they want to get reelected
in 3-4 months however long it is at this
point and people's lives actually depend
on this stuff send me your thoughts
about these atrocities that are taking
place I'm on Twitter at D Pakman and the
show is on Twitter at David Pakman show
I hate that I have to tell you this
today
I really do I take no pleasure in it but
at this point it is the undeniable
reality that the Oval Office and
President Trump the executive branch of
the United States government have been
completely subjugated and taken over by
Vladimir Putin and by Russia and this
became unendingly just glaringly clear
yesterday summit in Helsinki Finland and
especially by the absolutely atrocious
and embarrassing and shameful press
conference that was given right after
the private meeting between Trump and
Putin and I struggled today in planning
this segment because it's hard to know
where do you even start with this and it
was yeah I watched the the
conference it was one of the most
disgusting and vile performances by an
American president in in American
history I would argue and the question
is no longer if Trump is a subordinate
of Putin it's more a question of why has
he become a subordinate of Putin to what
extent is he a captive of the Russians
and how do we fix it that's really the
thinking pragmatically that's the number
one question and I admit that I didn't
expect the meeting was going to go well
but the historic low that was this press
conference given by Vladimir Putin and
Donald Trump is as I said of historic
proportions and during the press
conference there was a direct question
about Russian interference in the 2016
election which at this point is an
undeniable reality we know that Donald
Trump in his answer asked specifically
about do you blame Putin do you blame
the guy or don't you
Trump blamed everyone but the people who
actually did the interfering he blamed
Democrats of course Hillary Clinton why
not the FBI
Robert Muller a witch-hunt investigation
a Pakistani dude but not Vladimir Putin
and Russia and it is one of the most
disgusting acts that I can remember by
an American president certainly during
my lifetime during which I've been
paying attention to politics but it's
actually even worse than I've described
it to you up until this point Donald
Trump went further and said that Putin
had a great idea which was to have
Russian officials work with Robert
Muller on the investigation into Russian
meddling Russian actors are some of the
perpetrators and Putin says let me have
the perpetrators work with the
investigator and Trump called it quote
an incredible offer from Vladimir Putin
let's go to one of these clips and a lot
of the stuff I just mentioned is in it I
can't even keep track thank you a
question for each president president
Trump you first just now President Putin
denied having anything to do with the
election near Ference in 2016 every US
intelligence agency
concluded that Russia did what whoo my
first question for you sir is who do you
believe my second question is would you
now with the whole world watching tell
President Putin would you denounce what
happened in 2016 and would you warn him
to never do it again so let me just say
that we have two thoughts you have
groups that are wondering why the FBI
never took the server
why haven't they taken the server why
was the FBI told to leave the office of
the Democratic National Committee I've
been wondering that up and asking that
for months and months and I've been
tweeting it out and calling it out on
social media nobody where is the server
I want to know where is the server and
what is the server saying with that
being said all I can do is ask the
question my people came to me dan coates
came to me and some others they said
they think it's Russia
I have President Putin he just said it's
not Russia I will say this I don't see
any reason why it would be but I really
do want to see the server but I have I
have confidence in both parties I really
believe that this will probably go on
for a while but I don't think it can go
on without finding out what happened to
the server what happened to the servers
of the Pakistani gentleman that worked
on the DNC where are those servers
they're missing where are they what
happened to Hillary Clinton's emails
thirty-five thousand emails gone just
gone I think in Russia they wouldn't be
gone so easily I think it's a disgrace
that we can't get Hillary Clinton's
33,000 emails so I have great confidence
in my intelligence people yes but I will
tell you that President Putin was
extremely strong and powerful in his
denial today and what he did is an
incredible offer
he offered to have the people working on
the case come and work with their
investigators with respect to the 12
people I think that's an incredible
offer so the question is do you blame
Putin do you hold him accountable
everybody knows it was Russia
you blame him he says the FBI did bad
things
the DNC did bad things servers are a
problem Putin said it wasn't him I have
confidence in both Putin and our
intelligence this is gonna go on for a
while servers are a problem a Pakistani
guy is a problem Hillary's emails are a
problem he praises Russia slams his own
intelligence community he refers to
Putin as strong and powerful and says
Putin has made an incredible offer it's
over it's it's this might as well be the
Constitution of the United States Pat
it's over well when was how do you put
it this into words yeah I don't know if
you really can and I love that part
about you know Putin's going to be in
charge of dealing with Robert Moeller
and trying to get to the bottom of all
of this it's kind of like regulatory
capture in a way yeah what Trump is
doing with all his executive agencies
like let's put the climate change denier
in charge of the Department of Energy
yeah let's put the Colbert and in charge
of you know the EPA let's put the last
person you want to put the mom of an
alleged terrorist in charge of the
investigation into the terrorists why
not right I'm sure she'll have
incredibly valuable information to add
about her son this is actually in line
with what Trump wanted all along he
wanted to be in control of the Moller
investigation putting Russia in on the
Moller investigation sort of the next
best thing and the President believes
will add Amir Putin over our own
intelligence agencies this is the
perfect response if you were Putin right
if you're Putin and you're standing
there and they go to the other guy and
they say do you hold this man
accountable and Trump says it was
servers a Pakistani Hillary's emails and
this man was just so strong and powerful
and then he says he has no reason to
think that it would be Russia despite
all of our intelligence agencies saying
it with Russia despite all of the other
evidence that we have he's just says
well Booton says it wasn't them it just
wasn't them and if everybody who has
stated an opinion on this the only
person telling the truth if you believe
Donald Trump is Vladimir Putin the
person accused of the actual wrongdoing
so our country has been taken over we
are no longer in control we are no
longer sovereign and the major question
to be answered is why and we have a poll
on our YouTube channel asking this right
now was Trump bribed was Trump
compromise by Russia because they have
really damaging things on him we're
gonna talk about that a little bit later
is Trump just this open to suggestion
like is he this manipulable or is he
doing this because he's being
blackmailed I don't know the answer but
the White House is being subjugated by a
foreign power we suspected it for a
while but the press conference yesterday
has confirmed it beyond any doubt and
I'm increasingly thinking that Putin and
the Russians may indeed have
career-ending dirt on Donald Trump and I
mean not pp tapes I mean something even
worse that I don't even know what it
would be because this is the total
subjugation of a supposed big tough
American president by Vladimir Putin
it's got to be something right because
they receive no criticism ever you know
the European Union their apparent
terrible biggest foe to the United
States Canada hands on trade deal
there's hair hate oh maybe we should
pull out but Putin oh he denies election
meddling strong not a single criticism
not a single criticism and this is an
emergency this is it this is an
emergency
red alert this is a man who has to be
removed from office because we have a
president siding with a hostile foreign
power in direct opposition to our own
intelligence community it's traitorous
behavior when we imagined the worst case
scenario this is it and it's a reality
and we have to contend with it now and I
don't know what we do next so last week
we talked about democratic socialism
versus social democracy and I talked to
you about how especially since
Alexandria Acacio Cortez's win in New
York there has been sort of more and
more confusion as to what is democratic
socialism versus what is social
democracy and I did a story explaining
the difference democratic socialism is
actually socialism wants to remove
capitalism and replace it with
socialized ownership of the means of
production at least originally although
now there are people who say well
there's still democratic socialists but
they don't actually want that which
makes me question whether they're
actually democratic socialists at this
point and then on the other hand we
talked about social democracy which is a
progressive movement that wants to work
within a market economy within
capitalism and make it more of what I
call a socially guide
market economy and the difference is
massive and the confusion between these
two systems is very very problematic and
the top response that I got from people
in the audience was I mean of course
other than trolling was what's your
position David and I've mentioned before
that I'm not a socialist I'm a social
democrat in this sort of Nordic or
Swedish tradition and today I'm going to
explain to you why I am NOT a socialist
and I'm happy to do this it's something
that's been an area of study for me
since undergraduate and even even
including in graduate school and I'm
going to start sort of at the end and
then we'll walk through it fundamentally
I'm not a socialist because I want an
egalitarian free self-determining
Society and that type of society will
not emerge from authoritarian apparatus
and what that means is that at the
national level socialist and communist
structures are fundamentally
authoritarian and at scale enacting
socialism or communism becomes
authoritarian and a top example is
Venezuela let's assume in good faith
that the Shabbos Maduro goal was a truly
egalitarian free thriving society I
don't know if it was but let's be
charitable right and they really did
want that as the end goal when you put
aside the populist collectivist rhetoric
of that regime the Venezuelan regime is
an authoritarian imposition of
government without all sorts of freedoms
lacking in press freedom lacking in
judicial freedom it's a long list and
I'm opposed to it and whatever their
intern intentions were their imposition
of those intentions in this
authoritarian way has led to absolute
disaster and some socialists Leninists
will say that the opposition to the
Venezuelan regime is American astroturf
or that the replacement to Maduro might
be worse step back for a second an
authoritarian apparatus will not lead to
an egalitarian self-determining society
period but before we get to all of the
conclusion
we need to talk about what we mean when
we say socialism or communism
when did it start what does it actually
mean so for our conversation today when
I talk about socialism I'm talking about
modern socialism and communism in the
tradition of the 19th century and if you
go back to our socialism has never
worked debunked video we mentioned older
societies and sort of collectivist
iterations of economic arrangements but
for today we're talking about modern
socialist theory and that dates back
roughly to about the 1800s and there are
three main lines of socialist theory
almost no one who likes to talk about
socialism on the Internet actually knows
about this stuff this is really
important as the nuts and bolts first
you had the utopians in the 19th century
these are people like sense Iman Fourier
and Owen and their idea was that there
would be the development of these
collectivist egalitarian sort of perfect
as the name utopian implies societies
sometimes in isolated enclaves and they
would eventually spread and I actually
do believe that individually they can
work but once you say this is the system
for the country
it becomes authoritarian in its
implementation you'll develop conflicts
between these utopian enclaves but as
usual there was some good stuff proposed
there okay their theory applied to an
individual company or a commune or a
village it's actually a pretty good idea
I've just not seen evidence that utopian
theory can apply to a country of 300
million for example but I'm willing to
have my mind changed after the utopians
came the anarchists the sort of second
wave second line of socialists and the
main thing with the anarchist was that
government is the problem they were
actually a lot like the more extreme
libertarians of today for different
reasons than libertarianism the
anarchist socialist saw the government
mostly as an apparatus that reinforces
the status quo of class divisions
bourgeoisie versus proletariat or today
we could say corporate versus individual
interests or elites versus everybody
else and libertarians of course oppose
government for
different reasons but there was actually
a similarity there and that also doesn't
appeal to me as most people know I'm
against this on principle I think that
the government does have a role to play
but that being said the anarchists had
some valid critiques governments often
do become pillars of support for
corporate rule they do reinforce the
status quo they do reinforce power
structures I've seen no evidence that
eliminating the government is the
solution in the way that the anarcho
socialists or the libertarians believed
super-interesting that even though now
libertarians and socialists are mostly
diametrically opposed some of the
original strains of socialist thought
had a lot in common with libertarianism
they agree they don't want central
government because it's oppressive and
tyrannical but for different reasons and
then after the utopians and after the
anarchists you get to what are now the
most common versions of socialism after
utopianism and anarchism came Marxist
Leninist it together or Marxism and then
Leninism they're not actually the same
thing and they're once again there is
stuff of value if people could realize
that many of the critiques made by
socialism are actually really good we'd
be much better off some of the solutions
they proposed have only elements of good
ideas and in Marxism it's the Labour
theory of value extraordinarily
brilliant analysis of how capitalism
works which basically pointed out that
you have fixed costs like if you're
gonna make a product if you're gonna
make computers for example you've got
your fixed material costs you've got the
factory you need to buy the
semiconductors all of that stuff and
then you bring in workers and you pay
them something with the idea that they
add more than that to the total value
and that's surplus value you might have
in a hundred dollar computer fifty
dollars of parts and then 50 dollars of
added value if you can pay the worker 30
dollars to add 50 dollars of value
you've created twenty dollars of surplus
value this is a great analysis this is
this is an absolutely accurate analysis
the problem is I don't believe the
ultimate solution to that identification
is the end stage of capitalism with a
Marxist revolution that's not what I see
is the long-term solution
so again utopianism I don't think it
would work at the country level but for
individual companies or communes I think
it's actually a great idea to organize
co-ops and and shared ownership great
that has worked we can apply it to
healthcare we can apply to education I
don't see that as the solution to all of
society anarchism skeptical of
government government has become a tool
of the elites in many ways we see it in
the United States with Democrats and
Republicans using government as a way to
maintain the status quo it's a good
critique I disagree that eliminating
government is the solution and so what
previously had been sort of a cohesive
movement but with different approaches
utopianism anarchism Marxism Leninism
eventually what we saw around the time
of Lenin was a split between actual
socialists and those who went in the
direction of social democracy and I
believe that there are a number of
reasons why social democracy is the way
forward and socialism is not and in
explaining this to you you'll identify
many right-wing arguments against
socialism which I actually don't think
are good ones and this gets to one of my
fundamental opposition's to socialism's
view of the distributions of outcomes
versus social democracies socialism in
the Marxist Leninist sort of tradition
is simply not aligned with the realities
of human distribution because when we
look at human endeavors they have
unequal distribution if you look at
athletic ability and how its distributed
if you look at linguistic proficiency if
you look at business success if you look
at human height human weight it's all
distributed on a curve and on the one
hand where socialism wants to level out
with a distribution in a way that I've
not seen evidence can actually be
achieved without significant downsides
with social democracy wants to do is
tweak that distribution lower the
absolute top raise the bottom a little
bit and then reduce the gap between the
very bottom and the very top you're sort
of leveling it out you're raising the
mean and reducing the difference between
top and bottom I think it's important to
look at Sweden as an example the right
hates looking at Sweden Sweden's Social
Democratic Party which I identify with
was built on five principles that will
sound really familiar to Social
Democrats to people who follow Bernie
Sanders and those five principles were
number one an integrative democracy that
means and we can leave this up that
means that democratic decision-making is
the standard for legitimacy period real
democracy the people decide the
direction
number two the concept of the people's
home meaning solidarity and equality of
treatment as something that everybody is
committed to it there's no debate right
you need that number three
socio-economic equality and economic
efficiency are complementary these are
often considered opposing forces by the
capitalists right the the vulture
capitalist which is you can either have
an economically efficient society or one
that is more equal the social democratic
tradition actually sees those as
complimentary number four you have a
socially controlled market economy and
this is huge it's still a market economy
it's still capitalism but the economy's
direction and the priorities are
determined socially doesn't mean society
owns the means of production as in
socialism but society guides the market
economy and v proper expansion of the
public sector expands freedom and
freedom of choice
think about it health care for all let's
people get the jobs that are actually
their passion socialized education means
that people can really study what they
want rather than deciding on the
cheapest career to avoid student loans
this is all in line with my ideology but
it still exists within a capitalist
market economy that allows for
Entrepreneurship and individualization
and all of the good things that come
from the natural diversity of people
now when you talk about Sweden and you
talked to the right they will try to
destroy these talking points and you've
got to know how they try to do it a
popular went one is okay that that
worked in Sweden because Sweden is
homogeneous it's all white
it wouldn't work in a diverse country
this is patently absurd okay
the u.s. is 77% white Sweden is 85%
white okay the idea that those eight
percentage points are what make a system
work in Sweden and not in the US is
absolutely laughable it's also funny the
hypocrisy that many right-wing or
simultaneously claimed Sweden is being
taken over by brown immigrants and it's
chaos but at the same time
Sweden works really well because
everybody is white that should make
everybody say wait wait a second that
doesn't really make sense consider the
counterpoint if the United States were
all white would the Swedish model work
it's absurd the United States is huge
and with such differences in education
and religion and so many other things
just making the US all white would not
be what either makes or doesn't make the
Swedish system works now here is where
the critique actually defends social
democracy over socialism a totally
socialist society whether Marxist or
utopian or anarchist or Leninist in the
US would actually be impossible but what
wouldn't be impossible would be
socializing certain elements of American
society health care for example very
doable large countries socialized health
care education education could be put
into sort of the umbrella of social
welfare in the United States that's the
Social Democratic model that I support
one other argument from the right which
is they say it works in Sweden because
Sweden is small and the u.s. is big
that's part of why I believe that total
socialism actually is not the path
forward but that there are social Liza
Balcon ponents which would work
absolutely fine in the United States so
to sort of give you the highlights of
why I'm not a socialist and I am a
social democrat I believe that a
socially directed market economy that
reduces income inequality and ensures a
real standard of live
for everybody is more realistic and it's
also more in line with human nature
which actually shows that there is
distribution when it comes to any
endeavor that humans get involved in and
I fundamentally and this gets back to
the real reason that I so vehemently
oppose what we see going on in Venezuela
and what we see and have seen in other
places around the world I do not believe
because I've seen no evidence that an
egalitarian self-determining free
society will develop from an
authoritarian apparatus period I'm
willing to change my mind so let me know
your thoughts I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
and the show is on twitter at david
pakman show and I look forward to
dialogue on this issue going forward
yesterday it was called to my attention
that Ana Kasparian from The Young Turks
did a major takedown video against
intellectual dark web classical liberal
free speech advocate Dave Rubin as many
of you know Dave Rubin formerly was part
of the Young Turks he was also formerly
someone I spoke to on a somewhat regular
basis we even worked on a couple of
projects together when he was involved
with aura TV and I was involved with
aura TV on a web platform sort of
venture and as I think people in my
audience will attest my political views
really haven't changed much in the last
few years but Dave Rubin has become or I
guess you could say discovered that he
is a classical liberal and lately he
finds that the top truth tellers are
people like ben shapiro an extreme right
winger and others on the right and quite
frankly i don't know what dave rubin
thinks of me at this point we really
haven't spoken much since we did a
one-hour interview with him at this
point a while ago and in a piece that
ana kasparian did yesterday she cited
that interview which very quickly got
its first 125 150,000 views and it is
clearly going to get a lot of attention
here is just to kind of like set up for
context the reference that ana makes to
my interview with dave rubin in her
piece rubin declares that all decent
people must fight extremes
by judging people as individuals and not
as groups and then in another video he
states it's official leftism is a mental
disorder
political commentator David Pakman even
called him out on it
you said innocent in an interview with
ben shapiro that liberalism is basically
a mental disorder what did you mean by
that I don't think I said liberalism I
might have said progressivism right it's
not surprising to me that he goes back
and forth it's not surprising to me that
he lies and spreads propaganda it's not
surprising that he has completely
flipped the switch on who he is as an
individual and what his political
beliefs are so listen I I Anna Anna used
to be very close with Dave Rubin I
really don't know if Reuben considers me
anything at this point an acquaintance a
friend whatever I get a lot of emails
from the audience the gist of which is
David you know Dave Reuben can't you set
him straight on this topic or that topic
and the answer is no I can't I can't I I
have many friends with whom I disagree
with politically and it's no problem
but I just don't think that with Reuben
it's anything like that sort of
proactive nature I think I don't cross
the guys mind and I can't set him
straight on anything and I've sort of
made an effort not to participate in the
irrational Rubin bashing and if I
disagree on policy great I mean that
that was made clear during my interview
with Dave Rubin and I was actually I've
not mentioned this story before
Pat's taking notes I was approached some
months ago by a journalist at a media
outlet that you all know and they wrote
to me they said hey David we know you
were previously in touch with Dave Rubin
we want to interview I want to interview
the person said about Dave Rubin and the
writer said I'm also reaching out I also
reached out to Dave Rubin to get his
take and I got a strange feeling that it
was maybe a hit piece and so I contacted
Dave Rubin and I said listen this this
writer reached out to me I'm getting a
weird feeling
they say that they reached out to you I
have no problem talking to them about
policy I'm not
going to just hurl at homonyms that's
not what I do but did they reach out to
you because they said they did and Dave
wrote back to me and said they didn't
reach out to me and I think it's
definitely a hit piece and I went back
to the writer and I said listen I don't
want to participate in this because you
lied to me you said you reached out to
Dave Rubin and you didn't reach out to
Dave Rubin unless Reuben is lying to me
that's the last contact I had with Dave
Rubin and that was months ago and a
couple weeks ago I sent him a text about
something not at all related to politics
he did not write back to me and I I
really couldn't tell you what the
circumstances are the most common
question I get is do I think that Dave
Rubin really had a political awakening
or is he just doing this for money
because he's funded by learn liberty or
whatever Koch connected organization and
and the answer is I genuinely have no
idea because it doesn't really seem like
he has any interest in in having that
conversation with me but my impression
from the contact I did have with him
after his awakening was that he really
seems to believe this stuff I don't have
any reason to think that Dave Rubin is
playing any kind of a character whether
he's been sort of bamboozled into taking
these positions or not I couldn't say
but all the evidence I have is that the
positions that he espouses are his
genuine sincerely held positions